students meanwhile re recently capturing
more than a hundred people in separate
several
smuggling attempts this is in laredo
texas on the border is that city now is
still waiting for fema to arrive and
help out during the crisis want to bring
in the mayor texas mayor pete signs
there
in laredo how you doing sir good morning
to you i tell you
this caught my eye in laredo you had a
tractor trailer pulled over
44 people inside you had a commercial
tractor hauling a tanker 43 people
inside
you had another tractor trailer march 9
24 people inside
what are you up against mayor well
exactly that thank you for having me uh
this morning bill thank you so much uh
yeah just a brief description laredo's
about 160 miles
upriver from brownsville and about 600
miles down river from el paso just so
people
know we're the number one land port in
the entire uh
western hemisphere yeah but going back
to your question here yes
yeah we've been you know each region you
know the laredo cycle region is very
different than the rgb and of course the
el paso area in the del rio uh
you know we experience uh uh more
single adults uh uh from last year
compared to this year there's been about
140 percent
increase that's substantial uh and uh 90
percent of them
are or single male adults primarily from
mexico and of course these these folks
then uh
through the cartels through this
organized uh criminal activity that we
have in the border area on the mexican
side and of course it
overflows uh to a certain extent onto
our side although our city is very safe
but yet you know it uh matters of this
uh caliber do
you know occur you know they end up in
stash houses and then from the stash
houses
you know they end up boarding these
these uh tractor trailers or these vans
uh
so we've had a significant increase uh
you know close to
four thousand arrests uh uh or two
thousand arrests
and stash houses and uh i would say uh
about you know close to you know that
amount also
on on these vans and tractor trailers so
so as a mayor that concerns me because
obviously there's
volatility uh the potential of uh you
know things escalating and
and more overflow uh and i'm glad that
the border patrol is here and the
federal agencies yeah
let's do something but the head of
homeland security said the border secure
the border is closed is it secure
is it closed mayor no no
to both no questions and i heard that
yesterday from both
president biden and also from secretary
mallorca
yeah these are good words and i
appreciate that very much but words need
to be followed by actions
uh we haven't seen actions yet so does
it mean that uh
these these uhcs these these
unaccompanied children and families are
they going to be
turned away by using you know to
continue using title 42
and if not then then those words are
meaningless
uh so you know what do we do uh uh you
know obviously i think there's there's a
plan to
to amend the uh the asylum laws and so
the people can apply
from their countries of origin that'd be
great you know the point here being is
that
we need to prevent this this journey
from those countries to the border you
know it's
it's less risk uh life and limb and
money and so on uh to these folks but
also here in the community we're the
first responders
you are yeah it'll be cognizant of that
and uh
so yeah we need this thing remedy
quickly
thank you mayor pete signs he's he's got
a battle on his hands laredo texas right
on the border
thank you sir we'll stay in contact